you'll never find the balance the same
way that no young person will ever find
the perfect job
because there's no perfect company and
there's no perfect job and no one will
ever feel like they're making an impact
every day and no one will ever have
happiness every day it just it's just
you're not everybody's looking for
something that you literally cannot find
i'm trying to find you know a place
where i can be passionate every day
doesn't exist trying to find the perfect
partner for me doesn't exist
it's the the it's not about finding
something
it's about looking for it it's about
it's it's the it's the it's the best
it's when you say
find the balance it's it's not it's not
actually
this it's this
you don't want this yeah but it's this
it's always it's always teetering
it's always this it's always a slight
background you're always
blocking and tackling and that's the fun
because if it was stable you'd have no
fun
yeah again it's about being alert and
aware
the whole time yeah um
and and and i think that this it it
makes me really sad
that people set out on a journey to find
a part of
gold at the end of the rainbow where
there are no pots of gold at the end of
the rainbow
and they read books that tell them that
there is and they listen to speakers who
tell them that there is
and they go because somebody told them
there is but there isn't
and for me what i've learned is
what makes it joyful and exciting and
stable
and fun is who we take with us
on the journey that is the best part
that you don't go looking for the pot of
gold at the end of the rainbow by
yourself
for yourself how can i make an impact
how can i find the job that i love how
can i find the perfect mate
me me me me right but it's rather hey
you guys want to go for an adventure
i've heard there's a pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow
i don't know if we're going to find it
but let's go
and that that it doesn't matter if you
find the pot or not
the relationships that you build and the
journeys that you'll go in and the
storms that you'll
endure together and the hardships and
the funny things and the
falling on the floor laughing
that's that's life
and i think people get to take someone
on the journey with them
or volunteer to go on someone else's
journey with them